At the end of every episode of Journey To
The Microscosmos, we thank you for coming
on this journey with us as we explore the
unseen world that surrounds us.
But have you ever found yourself wanting to
have your own journey and explore the unseen
world that surrounds you?
Well you can start on your own journey with
the Microcosmos Microscope!
We worked with our Master of Microscopes James
Weiss to design what we believe is the perfect
starter microscope for someone who wants to
get into microscopy.
In fact, the clip you’re seeing on screen
right now was captured using our microscope.
We’ll have a whole video coming out pretty
soon where we talk more about our microscope
and show you what it’s capable of, but for
now, if you’d like to know more or pick
one up for yourself, you
can go to microcosmos.store
If you have been venturing through the microcosmos
for some time now, these oval green shapes
likely seem familiar to you.
They are not particularly distinctive, but
they are green and big enough to see
under the microscope.
And those two qualities describe a good chunk
of what we find in the microcosmos.
These particular little green organisms show
up in the background of other organism’s
lives, providing pops of color among other
debris.
And if you’re trying to identify what this is,
you might turn to some of the obvious candidates.
Maybe a euglenoid, or some kind of algae.
Something green and rod-shaped and single-celled,
possibly eukaryotic.
And if that’s your guess, we would
not blame you.
But you are wrong.
What you are looking at is not a single-celled
organism, but rather a gathering of them.
Those green bits are consortia of bacteria.
We’re going to explain more about what is
actually in that consortia, but before that,
we've got to tell you what a consortium is.
First, not all consortia are green.
Some are more like the colorless squiggle
you see in the middle of your screen, made
up of thin, curved prokaryotes gathered around
a central bacterium that
has flagella at both ends.
And “consortium” is kind of a funny word to
describe bacteria, isn’t it?
It makes them sound like a group of companies
that have come together to sign some fancy
legal document.
Which I suppose in a way they have.
There isn't a legal document binding them
together.
There is simply survival.
That word “consortium” can mean a lot
of things in the microbial world, in part
because our understanding of what they are
is currently evolving.
But also, there are just a lot of different
contexts in which they seem to appear.
When the term was first introduced to the
microcosmos realm in 1872 by naturalist Johannes
Reinke, the idea was to describe how an organism
can actually be made up of two species that
have somehow found a unified body to live in--
organisms like lichen, made up of algae and
fungi.
But the specific ways that organisms intertwine
their lives can vary, and for our purposes
today, the definition that probably best applies
is that a consortium is a group of bacteria
that are organized and are in permanent contact
with one another.
There are various types of consortia that
scientists know about, including formations
that live in your own mouth.
These consortia can be distinguished from
one another by their color, and their shape, the
number of cells within them, and the shape
of those cells.
And what makes them all special is that these
are relationships formed
entirely between prokaryotes.
This sets consortia apart from other ventures
into bacterial symbiosis that we have explored,
which have generally involved bacteria seeking
out more complex eukaryotic partners.
For example, there are the bacteria that live
on the surface of the ciliate kentrophoros
so they can hitch a ride to regions with enough
hydrogen sulfide for them to convert into food.
So this property of consortia
only being relationships
between prokaryotes makes this really fascinating
to scientists for a few reasons.
One is simply that bacteria probably teamed
up with each other before they ever teamed
up with eukaryotess, and understanding how
they formed these relationships may help us
better grasp how they have evolved with the
world around them.
Consortia offer more than just history though.
They also might suggest different futures
for us, providing us with the means to understand
how we can use bacteria for everything from
farming to cleaning up oil spills.
But identifying and understanding these consortia
is challenging.
James, our master of microscopes, has been
baffled by what looks like a bunch of logs
glued together.
He thought there might be flagellates in there
along with the prokaryotes.
But when he tried separating the individuals,
he couldn't find any.
So for now, like most of the consortia we’ve
been looking at, the mechanics of this group
remain unclear to us.
Perhaps the best studied
consortium is Chlorochromatium
aggregatum, the small green group we watched
in the beginning of this episode.
They are found in lakes and ponds, typically
in areas with low amounts of oxygen and light.
The green bacteria are Chlorobium chlorochromatii,
a green sulfur bacteria that are photosynthetic,
but that are surprisingly adept at living
in low-light situations.
And yet, they do still need light, which would
be fine, except that green sulfur bacteria
have a problem:
they cannot swim.
There are ways around this problem, like the
green sulfur bacteria that just go up in the
water column by producing gas vacuoles.
It’s like balloon travel in the microcosmos.
And much like actual balloon travel, it can
take a few days for the bacteria to get where
they want to go, so not always the optimal
choice.
But that is not a problem for
Chlorobium chlorochromatii
because they have found a different way to
get around the microcosmos.
A colorless, rod-shaped bacteria called
Candidatus Symbiobacter mobilis.
Now we don’t have a good view of this organism
because in most of our videos, it’s surrounded
by the green sulfur bacteria that have latched
onto it.
But here you can get a glimpse of it in the
middle of a group of green bacteria assembling
a consortium around it.
The job of that central bacterium is to move.
Surrounded by anywhere from 20-70 of its green
sulfur bacteria companions, the bacterium
in the middle of it all takes the group to
light and to sulfide.
And these consortium members might be in
communication with each other to find the light.
But why would Candidatus Symbiobacter mobilis
agree to this relationship?
Well the most likely explanation is that they
get nutrients from their companions.
Now if that is truly the exchange being made,
then it’s a trade that has had a huge impact
on that central bacterium.
When scientists studied the genomes of both
Chlorobium chlorochromatii and Candidatus
Symbiobacter mobilis, they found that the
green sulfur bacteria didn’t seem to have
to change much to make the symbiosis happen.
The few genes they’d acquired that were
geared towards symbiosis helped make the cells
adhere to each other or changed the cell wall
a little bit.
In contrast, Candidatus Symbiobacter mobilis
seems to have lost a large number of its genes,
so much so that it cannot grow independently.
It needs the consortium to survive, and only
when the consortium divides can it divide as well.
When you say it like that, “the consortium”
sounds almost like a dystopian entity, one
that’s trapped the Candidatus Symbiobacter
mobilis into a life of shuttling green sulfur
bacteria around with no mind to its own needs.
But, like couldn’t that be said for any of
our own cells, they don't get to live their
own lives or divide at will.
If they do, our immune system will kill them
because uncontrolled cell division is very
dangerous to the larger organism.
This consortium is, in a way, a wholly other
kind of organism, one that you likely have
never even heard of.
At its heart is a species of prokaryote
that cannot survive outside of it.
The closer you look, the more you realize, life
does not let us draw hard lines around anything.
It simply does what works.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And if you want to open your eyes to the bizarre
world that is just outside your door
and also in your own body,
don’t forget to check out microcosmos.store.
We just want to bring more people into this
amazing community.
So check it out, and maybe you can pick up
your own microscope,
or, if you just want to show your love for
microscopy and microscopic organisms, we
have things like hydra shirts, and tardigrade
mugs, and micro bumper stickers that you can
pick up to let everyone around you know that
you are a tardigrade enthusiast.
The people on the screen right now, they are
our Patreon patrons.
They're the people who let us and allow us
and enable us to make this content.
We are so grateful for them.
I really love that we get to make this show
and then I, along with you, get to keep learning
more and more about the microcosmos.
So thank you so much to all those people.
If you want to become one of them, you can
go to Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss.
Check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.